mesdames et messieurs
merci beaucoup d'avoir volé avec nous
je suis à alex dans l'avion salut
[musique]
nous sommes retournés à son hôtel
il n'y a pas d'échappatoire
quand je me suis réveillé le matin
[musique]
il était si vivant
vous pensez qu'ils
je  Je ne me souviens de rien à ce sujet Oui,
je suis votre meilleur ami, donc je dois vous demander
pourquoi l'avez-vous nettoyé, je
ne sais pas, d'accord,
je ne peux pas m'empêcher de penser à la façon dont ce gars en
3c est mort,
l'hôtesse de l'air qu'elle connaît.  plus
qu'elle ne dit que
le fbi voulait des informations sur toi je
vais continuer à creuser
ne fais rien de stupide
m'as-tu amené à l'enterrement de trois c
je suis une hôtesse de l'air folle et ivre, pas un
tueur